[音楽]
グーン
皆さん
こんにちは
奥様名前は岡崎と言います
生まれたときから
耳が全く聞こえません
皆さんは聞こえない人にどんなイメージをお持ちでしょうか
手話で会話する人
しゃべれない人
いろんなイメージがあると思います
でも実際は手話ができる人もいれば
できない人もいる
しゃべれる人もいればしゃべれない人もいる
みんな人それぞれです
聴こえ方もみんなバラバラです
僕の場合はどうなのか
僕の場合は
サボります
しゃべることがだるくてやって手腕を歩いて
皆さんは座って5勝10巻
障害というのは今僕が使っている手を動かあって花言葉です
一個一個の動くに海がありすべてが言葉になっています
今の社会は声で会話というのが当たり前だと思います
耳が聞こえない僕にとって雇用の会話というのは
なカムリタージュのとても苦労終え
女学校になるので m で結果割に
前でみんなのこっちの動きを見て何をしゃべっているのか
うちの動くからがんばって米とっている
正直あれまっ
朝から夜まで症っぽく千葉からもデーター
疲れない
それ new あると話し方によっては頑張ってコキの動きを見ていても何の喋ってる
のかさっぱりわからないときがあるもの
例えば
口をはっきり当てないと
しゃべるのが速いと
手でクッキーのか来ちゃうと
うん
もう
こんな風に別状鼎談の中ではこちらのうごでがゴムトレンドという状況がいっぱいあり
ます
なので会話の中身がわからなくなるとても正直
いっぱいあれば
だけど
手話ならばそんなことはありません
手話ならば頑張らなくてもみんなのはたちが旬と理解できるか
僕にとっては最高の言葉だなって思っています
だけど
この国で手話がリクルートはだったので0.06%で
ん
1500人に1人だけなんだ
つくらいでしょうねぇ
僕はこの市場をもっとたくさんの人に知ってほしい
覚えておい聞いて帰ってほじっ点を持っている
中では今日はをのば浮かれて皆さん
昭和のいいところをお伝えしたいと思ったらう
この残された時間で僕がどれだけ皆さんに芝居に興味を持ってもらうか
僕にとって言い体で大きなチャレンジだい
いたまりません
それでは早速いきましょうすごいのいいところ
味はガーター
いろんなだからだ台場ができる
難関はこんな状況ありがとうぞ
みなさんは今の状況ありませんだ
わー離れてるから声が届かないやー
うわぁ周りの歌カッコないよああああ箇所をひいて声が
てないよー
[音楽]
あると思う
でも大丈夫
ふわぁわぁ
使って来な言語に恋の多くたや周りのおもちゃかなんて関係ありません
ゾーン貼られてても大丈夫2つ
大丈夫声が出なくても大丈夫
ちょびーっといえば最強の健康な
坊主パティ具体的にお話しましょう
手話があるとこのような上等でも通わせることができます
一乗艇角度は
行かないといけない状況っていっぱいありましょうね
例えば
ドカーン
ブーッとか a
電車の中赤ちゃんが寝てる
フェアがた
持ってロールの成就かこんな時って周りに甘くならないように汁がなきゃって思い
ましょうな
でも大丈夫
市場はどんなときに声を出さなくても
じゅじゅかん通わせることができるんだ
便利ですよなぁうってこれを出さ月ても
か言うはができるということはこんなところでも
か言うはができるんだ
にでい
海がないん
僕は周りの友達と一緒に沖縄の有無にダイビング家に行ったことがあります
大田区は生むの中で食べるのはもう一度んをっ各は海の中で歌を買ってまと
皆さん
うむの中で歌を歌ったら何が起こるか知ってますか
魚が逃げます北
まあ眼科たジョン朴勝はどんなことも出たんて海の中で会話を直ちにでいたんだ
手話があったおかげでう
の中でも一般しゃべれて歌えても側の感動をとの場で宮することができたんです
中 by だからことをできる新しいた黎形でちゃな
あって手話があるとこんなときにも便利です
ラブラブなカップルは
雰囲気増でも長く人にたいと思うとお前
どんなときに編み中のは全チャでのバイバーのシーン
本当のカップルならば田たを扉が閉まったらそこで会話終了や室がー
手話の場合は
うん
バイバイまたねううバイバイまたね
うーんバイバイまたねー
ふーん
このように電車のドアが閉まった後も最後まで回奪う気に来ることができるんです
1分記号でも良子さ縁たいというカップルにはピッグたちのちゃなぁ
ませんかあれない
赤湯たに架空このように声で若い馬ができない状況でも主はならば
しゃべることができるんだこれは本当に便利なのでぜひぜひ皆さんも落ちめったになっ
て思っちゃいます
おってひまの湯た頃はまだまだって行きます浮き輪
カツラー
ジャーゲン役立ったかまるー
[音楽]
皆さんは
食べる時に表情やゼクターを生きていまった
往生とキャプチャーがあるのとないのでは
だまり方が大きく変えません
僕は履くから昭和使って喋ってるんですけども
表情と弱者の業とがいっぱいあるなって思いませんか
これにはワケがある
手話は手を動かすだけの言葉ではない
の気持ちを視覚的に表現貴方と思ったら手を動か口だけではありません
表情身体全体を使って表すことが大
俺は渋滞に a を見てもらいたいと思います
こちらで
私はチョイという文章があるバグは体の動くだけで現れますのでそれをご覧下さい
私はすごい
私は勢い
私は広い
どうなのか
なんか怖いですよね感情なんと怖いですよね
じゃあ表情とジェッチャーを入れてやってみたいと思う
大城戸ご覧ください
はいるからすごいこのセンスは凄い
私はすごい
e re
ありがとうございま
やっぱり衝動と10チャーがあるのとないのではた割方が全く違う街をね
あった方が絶対にいいと思いますよね
シュワーっていうのはこういう症状と受給者がペットになっている
言語ない
なのですわを使っていると自然に証言力が高まっていきます
表現力が高まればきっと職場でのプレゼンテーとにも使えると思いますし
日常会話の中でも自分の気持ちを蒼樹似合い店耐えられるようにあるんじゃない
でしょうか
思っております
あって今のいうところはまだまだて来ません
法的は各らー
んだんだん系な役なる
[音楽]
皆さんは
誰かと食べるときちゃんと相手の顔を見て食べていますか
今の社会は悲しいことにお互いの顔を見て会話うつるっとが降って言ってると思う
島方へた割りながら食べたりゲームながら喋ったリーク
雇用の会話だと相手の顔を見なくても会話ができるので
コミュニケーションがザブンなり額なんだと思います
でも昭和の場合は不本意ではありません
昭和の場合は未来とてなので手腕を使って会話打ち方とくると自然と安定の顔を胸が葉
言われてるようになります
僕も友達と喋るときは必ず相手の顔を見てしゃべる前
相手も僕の顔を見ながらしゃべってくれます
このようにお互いの顔を見ながら会話を上げているといろんなことに美るくようになり
ます
作業場自分がしゃべってるときに
うんがしゃべった言葉をあえてがどのように感じたのか
相手の表情の変化からこれを感じ取ることができます
またそれだけではなく歩く岡村たたえた
あれ疲れてるアレなんかわかんないけどういつもと違う
みたいに言っても音の変化でもグループやすくなると思うんです
またそれ以外にもやっぱりお互いの顔を埋めながら海を張っていると
分の話をちゃんと聞いてもらえてるなっていう安全感が生まれます
ストって合ういてが笑顔に入ってれば
おいっち負けが鳴ります開いた後かな知事かおいていたらこっちもかなちー気持ちに
なれます
この逆だって送ります
このように主はっていうのは用監視役言葉なんだって僕は思っています
手話で会話できることは
言葉と言葉をやりとりするだけではありません
心と心のコミュに点灯を切ることでも来なかっていくと僕は思っています
良いコミュニケーションは良い人間関係を作ります
皆さんがも父はを使って周りの人とコミュニケーションをとるようになったらゲット今
以上に人間関係が作っていけるようになるんじゃないかなと思っております
とって背後にもウッド札でうわせてください
ん
こちらですっ
今まで色んな事を放って決まったがシンプルに他の g ということも手話の魅力の1
日だと僕は思っています
今は劇歌断酒といろんなエンターテインメントがありますがすごいを使った
パフォーマンチっていうのもこういったエンターテインメントの赤間に入るぐらいに
楽しいんじゃないかなって
僕は思っています例えば
こんなふう言っ
ています
スイープわーおったら
音波を張って a
いやーやり方はなんだぞ1つの動きを
ビターまた一緒に行ってくれば
ora 位
dirt 2位東大理三亜鉛とも3個はパウダー
そう
[音楽]
ダート叫ぶ大スター
道室賀前に乗って来たーーブルー
赤くダブル女募っただけだぞうーん
はいはいはいはいわっ
すーっは2翠峰2は主は2種わーーっっ
2通話中は主は中は普通は中は電話
シュワー
諏訪ちゅ明日は2 hour
[拍手]
これ立は左右町の父ちゃんはパク立つ
うーん
ブーダーツの誰かバカ松
月の断固わー交通ああ
度数2
だ両党番亭
物事安藤着であーこれはどうなんん
ああああっ赤江まだかなーおー
ねーわっしー4ああっ
ただしアーティスタッチタッチタッチタッチだったらしいよパーした
car だんだんた後ができません
アーチはてるのは勝手になるとワークてしまうから小さいのであの者はせないのお城
玉島
部リサーチフリーターって立ってくるなぁはううぅんっ
うわぁ薄いパターンは中割っちゃうわー
は町2普通は数は座ってははず
だー消えパーントゥダーツへパーインターインターチーター子
楽しい楽しいよしましょう通話中はすチェーンは中は食器スーパーしたら家大丈夫
一般たちだしたびたび合わせていますわー
あああーーいっ
皆さん
つばわー
楽しかったんかパーシー
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
芝居というのは覚えない人が使う言語というイメージが聞こえると思うんですけれども
手話っていうのはこういうなんとだけではなくゴールドにとっても生カキを振り抜いて
くれる
べくなものだと僕は思っています
なので今日の話をきっかけにたくさんの人が一番日本語を持ってポールととこうなると
がもっとたくさん com 次会等にできるようになるだきっと
は違うにとって暮らしが豊かに変わってくるんじゃないかと多くタイプは思っています
もちろん堺を変わるのは簡単なことではなれど
分かってます
でも平分
今日皆さんが一番は誰だちって言ってくれたから
僕たちは未来にあたる希望
鑑定ます
これからも来たつはこの芝店大抵メントを通って立ったんぬっとに千葉の魅力を変えて
いきますとって
市歌を超えるとと号ないとがお互いに
倉地立社会を必ずをの手で作っておきます
皆さんもぜひ聞かがわかってください一緒に旧は終わりまでどうぞあありがとうござい
ましたーーー
ありがとうございましたーーー
[拍手]